What is the best glue comator to buy are the dotted base of ones? Okay. Yeah, you could buy any glue comator on the market
I just personally I have only used the finger prick ones that you could buy at Walgreens or Target or Walbark
They're up, you know, maybe thirty five forty dollars. They come with a hundred sticks
If you're not if you're doing it every day, you know, when you're checking your blood sugar every day as a diabetic then certainly getting the
The thing that's attached to your arm, then you're checking it with an app on your phone is certainly less invasive and it certainly
Would be easier if your hand diabetes and your monetary insulin levels. I would say that would be much
You know easier on you as far as having it prick yourself
But if you're not
Treating in full diabetes treatment right now and you're just wanting to check your blood sugar
Maybe you know four times a week to begin with and down to twice a week or something. It's pretty easy to do a finger prick
So I think I would probably go that route